in the current age of gaming there is a
ton of games out there
today's video is the first of a long
series why ramble for probably longer
than i should about games i enjoy and
mostly games that are quite old and the
first video of the series will be about
fallout 3 a game that's been out for 12
years but a game i still come back and
play
time and time again well not my personal
favorite fallout game fall 3 has some
incredible mechanics and features that
just make it all the more exciting to
play again from its incredible side
quests to story to dlc to setting let's
wander the wasteland one more time and
talk about the world of fallout 3.
this video assumes that you've played
fallout 3. while it's not a requirement
of course it would help to have some
background knowledge of some of the
things brought up in the video but as i
said it's not a requirement so even if
you haven't played the game you could
still sit back and listen for those who
haven't played the game or need a
refresher though let's go for what
exactly is
fallout fallout 3 is 200 years after the
bombs fell in washington dc
ford has never given the player a name
more of an identity but faulty's
protagonist being the lone wanderer
someone who grew up in one of the vaults
the intro has many time skips of our
early years from birth to baby to
teenager just to get us equipped with
what life is like in the vault
until we wake up one day and our father
has left that vault something completely
forbidden and arguably the worst crime a
valtteweller can commit we have no
choice but to leave the vault alone in
search of our father hence the name the
lone wanderer from a gameplay
perspective fallout 3 added some
original mechanics and unique twists on
the usual mechanics and rpg games
skills and perks are a staple of the
genre and while those do exist in
fallout
they are organized slightly differently
your beginning stats are called your
special stats which let you change your
character to your liking more strength
means more carry weight more luck has
the potential to land more crits
things of that nature leveling up is xp
base which you earn by discovering
locations completing quests and killing
things you're then given skill points to
put into the many categories before you
all of which give the player a brief
idea of what this increases
afterward comes the option of picking a
perk to add more strength to the
character some of these skills and perks
can be useful in checks during dialogue
to either complete an objective quicker
or hear the unique dialogue fall 3 also
has a karma system like the paragon and
renegade of mass effect but i always
found that it closely related to the
good and evil system of fable certain
actions can give negative karma or
positive karma to the player disarming a
bomb gives positive karma but stealing
would give them negative karma each have
their own reasons for existing in the
game's world but fallout's unique
mechanic is vats or vault-tec
assisted targeting system activation of
vats pauses the game allowing the player
to select different body parts to attack
we'll delve more into this in the combat
section of the video but that's just the
general basis of what vats is
while we will be discussing lots of
fallout 3's quests and missions all of
them have something
in common which is they all take place
in the capital wasteland minus the dlcs
all your time will be spent here
discovering locations
looting killing bad guys killing good
guys all of it is in here in the capital
wasteland it's a post-apocalyptic
version of dc
with some original locations like rivet
city but also real-life locations and
monuments like the jefferson memorial
throughout the wasteland you come across
a relics of the past old vending
machines and buildings that while aren't
untouched aren't also completely
destroyed either because the primal
nature of the world that means people
are going to act in
primal ways people of the wasteland
would rather shoot you than speak with
you
everyone is now fending for themselves
in this wasteland and can sometimes even
join groups
the wasteland is the furthest from safe
with drugged up fiends all over the
place looking for the next person to rob
as well as the super mutants who will
mutilate any human they find it's harder
to find a safe place in the wasteland
than a hostile one of course the
factions mark their territory with
dismembered hanging corpses usually
symbolizing raiders and bags of guts
being the super mute so you know what
kind of situation you're gonna be
dealing with but not everybody is bad
like the people
of megaton and rivet city who are just
trying to provide a peaceful residential
experience away from the harsh wasteland
to make the people feel at home again
then there are the neutral places people
like to stick to themselves like the
people of andale and canterbury commons
people who extend a helping hand to
those in need but
aren't crowded like rivet city and
definitely are kidnapping people like
the raiders
well maybe of course that leaves the
lone group of the vault dwellers neither
bad nor good as they can't have any
contact with anyone outside so to them
they just assume that they're the only
ones left while the individual vault
dweller may be an [ __ ] to someone the
whole faction as a whole doesn't really
have a specific side to play so they're
just neutral these places bring life to
the wasteland as ironic as that sounds
that's why exploring this fun to do in
this game
not only gameplay-wise you're getting xp
and leveling up but you're learning more
of the story of the game
meeting new people and just taking the
scenery fall 3 is a large world with
many places to go and there are a few
iconic places i wanted to bring up to
convey the range of these places one
might encounter there are the neutral
places that we discussed before like
andel canterbury commons and arafu
simple residential areas but have a
deeper story andale seems like a small
rundown block of houses with a few
residents everyone is happy though
like too happy as we figure out one of
the houses in the basement has corpses
of random wastelanders the residents
have been eating people who come to town
to feed on their families and don't take
too kindly to visitors who invade their
privacy the rfa residents have taken the
liberty of living on a broken highway
with one entrance and one exit
except they've been targeted by a group
called the family self-proclaimed
vampires
one of the residents of arafu was taken
by the family and is confused on what
side to choose as it's a decision that
will determine his whole future he can
stick with the family but he has to
drink blood for the rest of his life or
he can go back to arafu but now he's
considered an orphan as his parents are
dead and the townspeople are having
trouble defending the family anyway so
who's to say they won't just take him
back the people of canterbury commons
have had a peaceful life until it became
a battleground for two people
the antagonizer and the mechanist the
wasteland really brings out the most
interesting people sometimes
especially like the people who just want
to live it up even though the world is
ending like dukkhaf who has had more
bottles of alcohol in his room than i've
ever seen in my entire life
like seriously where the [ __ ] does he
get all these of course every now and
then you'll come across the more
questionable places like paradise falls
a group of slavers that just house
slaves so they can be bought you can
even join them and capture people for
them for caps
definitely a place you want to avoid if
you're just a normal wastelander roaming
around in the waste
a very common yet less talked about part
of the game is the metros and there's a
lot to find
underneath the wasteland while it's not
the most visually pleasing of places as
most areas do look the same they are
useful for the wanderer who wants to
find tons of loot as long as they're
okay with the abundance of raiders super
mutants and ghouls that also like to
take refuge in here besides the morally
good places like rivet city as we've
already mentioned them the last places
we haven't briefly discussed yet are the
vaults the vaults while cool haven't
really been a large selling point
there's the promise of a new world to
explore
places to go and the rpg elements that
are marketed it's never been about the
vaults they're usually just used as a
beginning setting for the main
protagonist
except players know why they're so great
as they're not exactly what you think
there are 122 vaults in the united
states
17 of those are normal vaults i say
normal as the whole point of them was
not to protect the american people
that was more of a front to hide the
experiments they would perform in there
each vault in fallout 3 has some
underlying story
for the player to discover once the
player finds out that everything isn't
what it seems they now become a huge
part of the future games and when they
buy those future games like new vegas
and fallout 4 exploring a vault isn't
the same anymore
something sinister is going on in there
and you want to figure out why fall 3
has 6 vaults all of which have a purpose
for example the starting vault 101 was
supposed to be closed forever so that
vault tech could study the effects of
the leader when it never opened and how
inbreeding would occur considering new
people wouldn't be entering the vault of
course
there are two other vaults we come
across in the main story vault 87
and 112. we'll go over these areas more
in the story section of the video just
remember that these two vaults also
existed out in the wasteland for the
player to explore the three that we
haven't talked about that are optional
are vault 92
106 and 108. vault 92 only housed
musicians with the goal of preserving
the musical talent in the wasteland
except the true purpose of vault 92 was
to act as a testing round for the
creation of super soldiers by the way of
subliminal suggestion they did this by
exposing citizens to white noise that
contained hidden messages as a form of
hypnosis once this step was achieved
they would use hypnosis to make obedient
super soldiers it worked but had
disastrous effects as the inhabitants
were filled with insatiable aggression
and deteriorating mental states one
subject killed three guards before being
put down and that was
after 23 bullets had been already shot
into him and one female residence
running became more and more
incomprehensible as time went on
to make matters worse the bottom of the
vault was flooding and since the
residents were all crazy not doing
anything it explains whether there's an
abundance of mirelurks upon arriving
vault 106 was just like 92 with a
seemingly normal vault minus the
experiments of course there wasn't some
out-of-place room made to kill people or
anything but psychoactive gas was being
pumped into the air systems as these
dwellers were used for drug testing and
the overseer knew all of this and was
instructed to tell people that
everything was fine
upon entering inside it's just torn
apart with insane survivors roaming the
halls there was a mini nuke and ammo
near the entrance possibly implying they
tried to blow their way out but that
proved unsuccessful
the drugs are still being pumped into
the vault when we arrive as well as we
can see tons of hallucinations while
we're here people like butch
amada and our father constantly appear
and at one point attack us when walking
through these halls
our last fault and my personal favorite
is vault 108.
as you can tell there are tons of people
who look the same named gary the vault
was supposed to open up in 38 years
except the overseer would die 40 months
into surfing the vault the main power
supply would die after 20 years and the
vault contained triple the normal ammo
stock and zero entertainment recordings
a pretty terrible vault to be placed in
while cloning is a questionable method
of reproduction given the circumstances
the vaults being put in already
regardless all the clones became hostile
to people who weren't gary and after 53
attempts nothing had changed so there
was 54 gary's in the vault residence
which the gary's overpowered and have
now seized control of the vault this is
one of fallout 3's biggest what the [ __ ]
moments as it's just
gary and nobody but gary is in this
vault the vaults have always been my
favorite thing about fallout as the
story to them is just so unique and
interesting that you just want to
discover all of them to find out what
new sinister thing is behind the giant
blast door
and all of these places make up the
wasteland rivet city the vaults and dale
the metro tunnels and anything else we
haven't mentioned
all make up the capital wasteland a vast
world to explore and uncover all the
small secrets about each location
whether it's a large
obvious story like the vaults or small
places like super duper mart that don't
really have a backstory but you can kind
of make some inferences just by noticing
the environment around you while some
places you can just look around
loot and leave not every place is like
that to completely go through an area
you're more than likely going to have to
fight your way out or talk your way
through it this is where the gameplay
and combat of fallout 3 though comes in
from the moment you start you're given
their choice of selecting the special
stats these seven stats provide bonuses
to the player depending on how you want
to make your build for your character
this is a good start to making one
characters of big guns will need
endurance and strength so the carry
weight is high enough to carry those
large weapons
people who want to suave talker will put
points in a charisma so their speech and
barter increases
simple as that and if you decide you
want to switch up your build there's
always ways to add more
points sometimes it's as simple as
getting a perk that adds points
sometimes it's being addicted to drugs
the entire game
after this it's on the player to level
up this can be done by successfully
hacking or lock picking completing
dialogue checks killing enemies
discovering locations or completing
quests once leaving the player has a
large selection of skills and perks to
choose from everything shown
is every skill in fallout all of which
have their own benefits and depending on
how you spec your special the number
could be different than mine in the
beginning i don't really think i need to
read out all of them as the names are
pretty self-explanatory and of course if
you played fallout 3 you already know
what these do
afterwards is a plethora of perks each
have certain conditions skills like
bloody mess only require level 6 but
some perks require a high enough skill
level or special stat
size matters which increases the big gun
stat is a level 8 perk but also an
endurance of 5
but perks like mr sandman are level 10
perks but also require a sneak of 60 to
unlock what i want to mention and
applaud with esdefore is flexibility or
somewhat of it in the beginning of my
playthrough i wanted to use base guns
combat shotgun assault rifle 10 mil
pistol but i changed and wanted to
switch things up to gatling lasers
missiles and fatmans because who doesn't
want to blow [ __ ] up my specials really
didn't help with this and i did this
sort of in the middle of my
current playthrough so i had to level up
to get those skills and big guns the
highest level in fallout is
20 or 30 if you have the broken steel
dlc but assuming you prioritize the
leveling up fast and getting more skill
points per level you can max out many of
the trees in the game
currently in my playthrough i made for
this video i'm level 27 and only 6 out
of the 13 trees aren't level 100
it'll most likely go down to 4 instead
of 6 as 2 out of the 6
trees are around 70 in level regardless
you can max out many of the stats just
from prioritizing your leveling properly
going for perks that increase xp gain or
putting points into a stat without you
actually putting any of your current
points in it
negating the worries of creating a build
mid playthrough and that's just from
leveling up there's books
armor and bobblehead stats that can
increase this even further some armor
alters the skills to increase or
decrease its value and reading a skill
book can give you one level to whatever
skill that is but prioritizing and using
the comprehension perk can give players
two points
according to the fallout wiki most of
these skills have 25 skill books in the
game and there's a bobble head for every
special stat
and skill each skill bobble head gives
10 points and each special bobble head
increases that stat by one so in theory
a player could max out every tree by
getting the skill to level 40 via
leveling up then getting all the skill
books in the game with the comprehension
perk enabled making them all 90 then
finding every skill bobble head turning
it to level 100 on every skill now this
is the one percent strategy as most
won't bother to find all these and just
level up normally but going back to my
example getting more than two-thirds of
the skills in the game maxed out doesn't
really give you a build
yes in the beginning to mid-game you can
customize your build putting skill
points where you want but you have to
put those points somewhere so you have
to dabble in other skills once you've
reached the cap
i didn't even really care for explosives
or sneak but i needed to put the points
somewhere and it started becoming less
of a designed build and more of into a
powerhouse with a fully busted max out
stats basically being the master of all
trades and that's always been my biggest
gripe with fallout but i understand it
though it's rewarding the players who
put that time in to level up this much
so i'm not going to nitpick too much on
it
of course in between leveling up you are
killing things with the help of vats
that's as stated before was the
vault-tec assisted targeting system
which pauses time to allow the player to
select different parts of the body next
each body part is a percentage and a
health gauge the percentage is a
combination of different variables like
the current weapon you're wielding the
amount of visibility of the body part
accuracy stats sneak attack distance
between player and target and tons more
all adding up to a percentage of zero to
95 the higher the number the more likely
you are to hit that body part the health
gauge shows how close a limit is to
crippling you would think just hit the
head simple as that but each [ __ ]
provides bonuses
crippling the head makes accuracy worse
crippling the body makes the target
flinch more
crippled arms also decrease accuracy but
can even make the target drop their
weapon
rippled legs make the target walk slower
making it easier for them to hit again
as they try to limp the cover
you can even quote unquote [ __ ] the
gun breaking it entirely or sending it
flying out of their hands
of course not every creature and fallout
is built with these body parts so things
like ants robots and turrets have other
parts of them like a sensor no matter
what though each part provides a bonus
should it be crippled making all options
viable and not just the head
vats uses ap or action points and each
gun uses a set amount of them
things like pistols can fire many rounds
before running out of ap
but missiles aren't as fortunate of
course if you dislike vats or don't want
to use it in a specific engagement
typical fps shooting will work just as
well and sometimes is even more
effective
each use of ap with an ar will shoot a
couple bullets in a burst but if the
target's health is low enough for only
one bullet then you're just wasting ammo
and weapons like the missile the flamer
and the minigun i find more fun just
shooting without bats as you can put in
more rounds into them killing them
faster instead of going through some
scripted sequence of the player shooting
especially with the minigun where it
needs to spin before firing and vats
cancels that making you spin it again if
you want to shoot it limbs can also
[ __ ] without the need of vats too
that just helps make sure that you shoot
the correct body part instead of
spraying everywhere if your aim isn't
good enough bethesda provides benefits
to both ways but not allowing too many
benefits that one overpowers the other
which makes a nice healthy medium
but you can't use vats without weapons
right thankfully there's tons of weapons
to choose from unarmed melee small guns
big guns and energy weapons there's
loads of options for those who level up
a specific skill
and if you take a liking to a specific
gun say a hunting rifle or combat
shotgun there's more than likely one
maybe two versions of the same gun but
with a unique name and different stats
for example the hunting rifle unique
version is called old
painless the difference being that it
does more damage per shot a faster
reload and a faster rate of fire
most of the unique guns do simple stat
increases like that but some aren't so
simple the metal blaster shoots nine
beams for the price of one allowing for
massive damage assuming they all hit
the unique weapons have always been a
nice touch of the game especially
because there's only one of them in the
game so dismantling them or selling them
is not recommended unless you truly
don't care about the gun at all
meaning there is some real quality to
these weapons when you find them all of
these mechanics are the basis of fallout
killing things leveling up looting
places talking with people and getting
quest and all the previous things we
mentioned the skills the perks the
weapons and the vats are all within
those circumstances as well while the
idea of exploring the wasteland with all
the mechanics the game provides and the
plethora of places to explore is
entertaining there needs to be something
that pulls the player in
or at least be used to make sense of our
actions which is the main quest of
fallout 3. before we can even do
anything we mentioned throughout the
past 20 minutes we have to get through
the intro
as a baby we are able to pick our
special stats and listen to our dad talk
about our mom's favorite bible passage
when we turn 10 we're throwing a
birthday party and given the legendary
pip-boy and able to finally interact
with the vault populace
when we turn 16 we take the generalized
occupational aptitude test and get to
meet all the kids now as adults
the goat decides our skill points we
mentioned earlier even though we can
change them whenever we want this is
easily one of the best parts of the
intro
he who shelters us from the harshness of
the atomic wasteland
and to whom we owe everything we have
including our lives
after the goat you wake up to the sound
of amata more years into the future
saying that our dad has left the vault
and that we need to leave too or we're
gonna get killed as we leave we'd
explore the wasteland to our hearts
content
we'll be focusing on the main story for
now currently our main objective is
finding our dad and talking to various
people we go from collin to three dog to
dr
lee trying to find him alternatively if
you remember where rivet city is located
you could just run there and skip the
other two people and never talk to them
mentioning three dog would be a
fantastic transition to the music on the
radio in fallout 3 but
youtube's already foaming at the mouth
ray to claim my video the moment they
hear it so in an effort to at least have
it mentioned in the video the soundtrack
is some of the best music in a game i've
ever listened to and clearly reflects
the time period of the old technology
that the game has besides this
playthrough i don't remember the last
time i didn't play a fallout game
without music
on it's one of the best additions to the
game and three dog is such a comedic
relief to help paint a better picture of
the wasteland even though the
circumstances of the world are pretty
[ __ ] no matter what way you approach
this quest we learn more about our
father and his goals
he had been working on a project called
project purity with the intention of
turning all the irradiated water into
purified water again it was basically
what the vaults used to get clean water
but on a much larger scale
our dad didn't live in the vaults he
came to vault 101 when we were born so
he could raise us in a safe environment
the project wasn't getting any results
for a long time so morale and support
dwindled which is why he then abandoned
the project
later he realized he needed to restart
project purity up again as he may have
found an alternative method that would
make the project work and that's why he
left us assuming we wouldn't chase after
him
this alternative was the geck the gecko
was used to help vault weather's
repopulating grow communities fit with
items used for power consumption
seeds for farming and other necessities
it was the perfectly packaged device for
a post-nuclear world that was for the
vaults that were meant to open
remember how i said vault 101 wasn't
supposed to open that means it didn't
have a geck
dr lee points us towards the jefferson
memorial as that's where project purity
was started except he's nowhere to be
seen and there's a hollow tape that
points us to vault 112.
vault 112 is an interesting vault it's
very small with little things inside two
clinics and a giant room with pods no
mess halls no beds
nothing which is already suspicious as
it is upon entering the pod were
transported to tranquility lane
vault 112 was intended for 80 plus
occupants the reason there's a lack of
anything in this vault is because it was
only there to care for the needs of the
overseer dr stanislas brause the creator
of the gek and the little girl in the
simulation
dr braun used this as his plaything once
a person entered they would not be able
to leave as dr braun was under complete
control if he was ever bored he could
just virtually kill them wipe their
memory and resurrect them within the
program to start anew
it's always been up to debate on what
his true intentions were with his
experiment
if all he intended to do was toy with
them then he succeeded but if he was
really a simple doctor trying to make a
peaceful safe haven away from the harsh
wasteland it seemed that it worked at
some point but then ended up being
corrupted by his god complex
since we entered we're just as screwed
as the original vault weathers trapped
in here forever but dr brawner betty
offers us a way out but we need to do
things for him like making timmy cry
cause a divorce and ultimately killing
the entire town or you can simply go to
the abandoned house trigger the passcode
and initiate the shutdown protocol which
has the chinese soldiers kill everyone
ultimately this ends with the dwellers
dying in some way either death by brawn
to be reborn again or legitimately
killing them with no resurrection
only difference is braun gets to toy
with them more or he's stuck in his own
simulation
alone for the rest of his life with no
way out upon escaping we find out our
dad was inside as well and he was the
dog doc which explains why he wasn't
dead after we slaughtered everyone
together you go back to rivet city and
meet with dr legan project purity is up
and running again now that the team is
back together but not quite yet as we
need to clear the mutants out of the
memorial and reboot the systems
we're almost done as we still need that
geck but a faction known as the enclave
have some better ideas with the project
and just as we're about to have a lovely
father-son talk after all these years
our dad kills himself in front of us
allowing us to escape the enclave have
the same plan as our father with project
purity making fresh water and
distributing it to the people the
wasteland except they plan to use it as
a method to get people to flock to them
for protection and water as a plan for
the future
james wants to give people water to help
others he doesn't need anything in
return
the enclave have other ulterior motives
with the charity of providing water just
being a front which is why they
shouldn't be allowed to have the control
of this project
after escaping the firefight we meet
with the brotherhood of steel a rival
faction to the enclave using the
technology that brotherhood has you
discover there's still a gack in vault
87
issue is that it's surrounded by major
radiation leakage and you'll most likely
die almost instantly
the only way through is through little
lamplight a camp made of only kids who
dislike adults their leader is a kid
named macready someone who you may
recognize in the future
mccready needs help rescuing his friends
from the slavers of paradise falls after
rescuing them he allows us entry into
vault 87
vault 87 is the last vault we visit in
the main story and the last one we
haven't discussed yet this vault was one
of the couple vaults that studied the
effects of fev
or forced evolutionary virus the
dwellers of the vault became subjects
and were tested on regularly some died
almost immediately but the ones who
survived became genderless beings who
were extremely muscular and tough
except as a side effect they were
aggressive and their mental stability
diminished this is where the super
mutants started in the capital wasteland
the one subject that was experimented on
but for some odd reason didn't lose his
mental state is fox
he is a friendly super mutant in vault
87 and saving him makes him a temporary
follower for the quest and since he's a
super mutant he also has resistance to
radiation meaning he can get the geck to
us
making this quest a whole lot easier
after obtaining the gek we are ambushed
and taken by the enclave president john
henry eden wants a word with us and
gives us the potential of an ending for
the last quest if we take the modified
fv he gives us we can sabotage project
purity the wasteland clearly needs
assistance
project purity is one part that's going
to help with that assistance the
abundance of ghouls and super moons and
other irradiated personnel in the
wasteland is also a problem that needs
fixing so with the fev vial we can wipe
out all of them
except the purifier isn't going to be
pumping off fresh pure water so it's
either pure water but the mutant schools
and radiated people roam free or
no mutant schools and irradiated people
but the water is still unpurified and
likely will still be for quite some time
giving the player a moral choice
no matter what your decision is we need
to escape this base and once we do a
fellow friend arrives to assist us
so we escape this facility and take the
fight to the enclave as the
anti-communist robot liberty prime is
ready to go this mission is more about
avoiding the giant news of liberty prime
then avoiding the bullets of the enclave
but it's great and comedic to hear
liberty prime shot anti-communist
comments while nuking the streets of the
capital wasteland
entering the room of the purifier we
have three options we use the code we
use the fev virus or we do absolutely
nothing
each option ends the game unless broken
steel is installed which we'll cover
later in the video but to activate the
code it's either on us or sent an
alliance to do so with the code being
the old passage our mom loved which is a
nice throwback to the beginning scene
this without broken steel is the ending
of the game even if the player selects
the lions to do so the only way to
progress in the game again is to revert
to last save and not finish the final
mission
this questline was pretty nice i'd say
was it revolutionary
no but it wasn't a terrible one and it
always bothered me how you could never
justify your actions is why you left
you couldn't tell your father that jonas
was killed and that we were next if we
didn't leave and find him
regardless though it's a nice questline
and still entertaining to play through
while the main quest drives the player
to the game it's the side quest i always
found to keep them hooked with so many
areas to explore there's many quests the
player can come across
and sink hours into fallout 3 like any
game of its kind has loads of side
quests and because there's so many just
like the marked locations i want to
cover a few that really show the true
diversity and strength of the side
quests in this game let's go back to the
bizarre town of canterbury commons upon
arriving we see two people fighting in
costumes the antagonizer and the
mechanist it's quite the sad tale
actually as tanya the antagonizer saw
her parents killed in front of her by
giant ants she was also a pretty huge
fan of the grognock comic series back in
the day and as a form of trauma took the
role of the antagonizer from the comics
as the super villain's origin story
closely resembled tanya's
the reason she attacks this town
specifically is because her family would
travel here quite often on caravan trips
and now saw this as a blight on the
wasteland the mechanist is a 40 year old
man
named scott who had a rough childhood
but ultimately settled down in
canterbury commons living a peaceful
life as the mechanic of the town it's
learned from some of the townsfolk that
during one of the antagonizer's rage she
destroyed one of scott's robot creations
which made him very upset and thus
became the mechanist to stop her the
townsfolk really don't care how you
handle it just that you do
and you have three options as well
killing one of them killing both of them
or killing neither of them and handling
it through dialogue which is the hardest
choice
it's not a particularly long quest since
their layers are super close to town it
will probably take no longer
than 10 minutes but i do like the added
detail of actually going with one of
them to fight the other and not just
handling the whole thing yourself as
well as the small sprinkle of story that
tells us how things got to be this way
as i feel like some quests just kind of
missed that mark entirely when roaming
the wastes on the north side some
players may encounter a gentleman known
as tree father birch and oasis
he rambles for quite a bit but then
mentions that we were summoned by him
him representing their god who we have
the pleasure of meeting their god is a
talking tree
if that's not already bizarre enough
what's even more bizarre is that harold
is not a talking tree
he's a human being well mutated human
being herald underwent those fev tests
we talked about earlier except his
exposure and reaction to the virus was
slightly different eventually forming
into this being we see here
inside him sprouted a tree-like species
called bob that slowly overtook him and
turned him into this tree
even though he is definitely in far than
ideal circumstances he still keeps that
comedic personality of his
as though even though the tree's name is
bob he always found it funnier to call
him herbert as it makes him mad harold
is sick of this place and wants to leave
and the only way to do that
is death so he hopes that you will grant
him that you could alternatively burn
him but he wants to go out painless and
not burn to death as he's afraid of fire
when exiting the sacred grounds a
conversation between mother lorel and
father birch can be overheard and the
two have some conflicting ideas both
appreciate herald as the god of oasis
but father birch sees harold as the gift
to the people of oasis
and wants to contain his influences to
not attract any unwanted attention from
the outside world laurel wants to spread
his influence past oasis so the whole
wasteland can benefit from herald and
his blessings so now there's a three-way
choice again surprisingly none of these
options are bad besides burning him if
you disobey harold he will mention how
he talked to father burch and realize
that these people would be lost without
their god so he needs to be there to
fill that role for them if you disobey
the tree minders father birch isn't
upset with you as he has a conversation
with harold and realizes what you told
him is the truth and he should have been
more open to harold than talking with
him more than just immediately writing
him off as some higher being
ruining the bond between them but thanks
to you in some way it's restored but
sometimes it's good to go back to your
roots
not those routes but your early
beginnings which is why it was really
cool to visit vault 101 again after so
long in the wastes
after seeing your dead die a vault 101
stress call is made by amada for you to
return once you enter you're greeted by
officer gomez the one guard that's
always been nice to us
there has been a feud going on between
the vault residents and the upper
security the vault residents led by
amada want to see the outside world they
don't want to leave permanently just be
able to come and go as they please and
still have a bed to rest at in the vault
but the overseer amado's father is still
trying to uphold his mission by keeping
the ball from never opening
the player decides the fate of the vault
and can use their knowledge of the world
as a catalyst for their decision
some players may remember the beauty of
megaton and that it's there to help the
survivors of the waste you need
residents but players can also remember
the creatures throughout the waste that
kill anything they see which may incline
you to keep them inside especially
considering that right near megaton is
spring bell elementary which is overrun
by raiders so one wrong turn and they're
all dead
each issue is acceptable to do assuming
you're achieving it through dialogue and
not killing the vault dwellers as that
is definitely not the proper way to
handle the quest you talk with both
sides of mata and the residents as well
as the overseer to hear their differing
opinions then you take the option you
prefer
talking to the vault residents was
refreshing as it's been ages since
you've seen them and it was nice to
catch up
you can even recruit butch as a
companion now if you talk to him but
i couldn't as i um well a big problem
that can help this decision is the
issues with the vault that we explained
in the previous section of the video
because the vault was never meant to be
open inbreeding was bound to occur and
the vault population was dwindling lower
and lower over the years if you convince
the overseer to let them go he agrees
after some time as he had noticed the
population wouldn't survive more than
another generation or so thanks to the
need to inbreed with the other members
causing genetic stagnation
alternatively you can convince amada as
you have firsthand experience how
dangerous the outside world is and that
staying in the vault is the best way to
survive
some people could see this quest and
help amado regardless because she was
the one that helped us way back when but
the people of vault 101 are a family to
you so it's only fair that you help them
out in their time of need no matter what
choice you decide to make our last quest
takes place in rivet city near dr lee is
an old man named dr zimmer he's looking
for someone a synthetic humanoid or
android is roaming around in the
wasteland and he has reason to believe
he exists in rivet city playing fallout
3 for the first time i thought
nothing of it but it was always crazy
how this was relating to fallout 4 a
dimension of since in the commonwealth
as well as the appearances of both the
institute and the railroad dr zimmer is
a part of the synth retention bureau who
lived in the commonwealth and travel to
the capital wasteland to retrieve high
profile units which we know are synths
to find the synth we need to find
holotapes of him or ask around the
commonwealth you can talk to dozens of
npcs to trigger this like moira and
megaton or some ghouls in the underworld
this isn't a quest you can do fast and
get it over with for players
first experience of this quest they'll
just have to hope that they come across
it at some point and assuming they
explore the world to its fullest
potential
they will there is tons of potential
dialogue choices and holotapes to find
to discover but once you find them a
person named victoria watts notices that
we've been snooping around just a bit
too much recently she mentions that she
is part of the railroad a group
dedicated to giving since their
independence
actually quite a few npcs like tulip in
the underworld father clifford and rivet
city and a few more are also secretly a
part of the railroad too while this
quest is great on its own it's always
thought that it was better to play this
after fallout 4. since the institute and
the railroad are some of the main
factions in that game it can influence
your decision entirely by playing
fallout 4 before doing this mission it's
not just about choosing zimmer or
victoria's choice it's much bigger by
choosing the institute or the railroad
and the repercussions of your actions to
those organizations
it's a quest in the beginning that when
it was just fallout 3 was fun and
definitely different compared to the
rest but truly got the love it deserved
when fallout 4 released when victoria is
done talking she will give us a synth
component and as we know from fallout 4
that is the one true way to identify a
synth and tell us to give it to dr
zimmer this shows that the android is
truly dead and he will leave us alone
you can instead travel to the broken
portion of rivet city and meet horus
pinkerton he is a surgeon and scientist
who created the android's new face
horus provides us with way more context
to the situation and even gives us audio
logs from the day he did the surgery on
the android
the only option after this is to
confront the android to tell him his
true identity harkness will ask that you
spare him and kill zimmer for him with
this plasma rifle you can either do what
he says or disobey him and turn him in
completing the quest all four of these
quests in their own way are fantastic
throwbacks to the early days of the game
hints from a future fallout game or just
being generally good quests
while either of them isn't long with the
exception of the android side quest
depending on how lucky you are with
speaking with people
they still do provide a breather in
between the main quests and are
rewarding whether that's in gameplay and
the ending reward or the story
as i said before i can't talk about
every quest as that would just be too
much time but i'd love to hear your
personal favorites my two honorable
mentions that sadly didn't make this
list but without or a doubt
fantastic the wasteland survival guide
and the power of atom
but at some point there comes a
roadblock you've done every quest or
you've explored every area but not all
is lost as within a seventh month period
bethesda would release five dlcs in
fallout 3. so let's start from the
beginning and flashback to before the
bombs fell with operation anchorage on
january 27
2009 three months after fallout 3's
release operation anchorage would hit
stores
it's crazy to think that this dlc and
the other four were in stores like
usually games have game of the year
editions or you just purchase them
digitally but
i still love the cases the packs came
from and back in 2009
it's a wild time seeing as this was a
blast to the past that's fitting this
dlc was too
operation anchorage takes us back to the
war in alaska between the united states
and china but it's not as simple as that
while wandering the wasteland just like
any other dlc we hear a radio signal we
follow that signal we meet the
brotherhood outcasts on their way back
home who need some assistance getting
back
the outcasts are ex-brotherhood of steel
members the reason they left was they
felt the current leader elder lions
divulged from the brotherhood's true
mission so they left they still uphold
that mission of scavenging the old tech
but are now separated from the group
the outcasts and the brotherhood would
eventually come back together a decade
later thanks to the truce by elder
maxson and he's also the same maxin in
volatile 3 just of course a little
younger at this current moment
you can follow the group inside and talk
to the leader protector mcgraw the
reason the outcasts are down here is
because there's a locked door with some
possible pre-war tech inside and they
want to scavenge it except they need a
pip-boy to get through and we just so
happen to have one but just like the
whole dlc it's not as simple as it seems
we need to complete the entire training
simulation of the battle of anchorage
where the dlc truly starts
in the simulation the player is stripped
of all their equipment and weapons and
forced to fight with what they have you
aren't allowed to dilute every cabinet
of the simulation and enemies disappear
upon death so the only way to get ammo
heal or find new weapons is the various
stations throughout the map which are
highlighted in red completing the
training simulation is simple kill the
general of the chinese army but there's
a lot to do before that with sergeant
montgomery we have to take out the three
aaa guns pelting our reinforcements then
we need to take down the two sections of
chinese forces
remove the pulse field then we can face
the general the enemies are all roughly
the same there are some flame units
regular foot soldiers and then the
occasional special enemies which are the
chinese snipers who are cloaked even
during combat most of the dlc is going
from point a to point b
shooting anything that isn't american
and finding the glowing red stations
the game does give a lot of different
types of weaponry though like assault
rifles 10-mile pistols missile launchers
goss rifles and snipe rifles to give to
you the second portion of the dlc when
you make it to the base switches things
up you're given five markers and a
supply hollow tape
this supply hollow tape allows you to
pick a set of different classes whether
it's up close combat with a combat
shotgun and power fist or heavy weapons
with rocket launchers in the submachine
gun there is enough ammo stations and
options for all classes to work so
everything is viable and the markers are
for your team you're also given a range
of options from these two
infantry men mr gusties and century bots
can be put on your squad and the better
the unit the more markers it takes not
only are they helpful as you do have a
limited ammo at certain spots it's
actually necessary like the captain of
the squad to be able to do something
with that title other than just having
the name
after everything is done you then fight
and kill general jing wei this completes
the simulation
and allows the door to be accessed the
sheer amount of loot in here
is insane everything from the simulation
and more is inside
power armor gas rifles flamers missile
launchers plasma weapons and tons of
ammo and because you completed this you
receive power armor training which is a
much faster method than doing it through
the main quest
while being distracted by the sheer
amounts of loot in this bunker you may
not notice that some of the people in
the outcast want to take the loot for
themselves and not share which causes
the mutiny and everybody starts killing
each other there is the possibility of
saving mcgraw and olin but seeing as
once they're saved to go right back to
being [ __ ] to you maybe
it's better that they died thanks to not
needing equipment for this as it strips
you for your simulation you can do this
very early in the game around level 4
and level 5 with power armor and these
busted heavy weapons and if you're
patient enough you could bring all this
armor to rivet city or megaton and sell
it for tons of caps making this a truly
worthwhile dlc
and only takes a couple hours to
complete two months later on march 24th
was the release of the pit which takes
place in the post-apocalyptic ruins of
pittsburgh this starts via radio signal
from a man named werner who is in need
of our help winner needs help retrieving
a cure for the mutations that plague the
town this cure is being held by the
raider boss asher
warner needs us to get a disguise so we
look like a slave and once found we walk
across the bridge into the pit with our
goal in mind the pit was not directly
hit by atomic bombs during the great war
the water from the nearby river soon
became highly irradiated a few decades
before fall 3 started the brotherhood of
steel sent a raid team into the pit
they killed all the raiders who occupied
and anybody else who fought back
during this an explosion erupted in the
steel mill and asher was the only one
caught in the explosion he was presumed
dead which is why the brotherhood never
bothered to rescue him he was then saved
by scavengers and eventually became the
leader of the pit
one of the issues that the only people
alive in the pit were raiders and a few
scavengers so they needed slaves to
increase the population and produce more
steel at the mill
the people of the pit could not have
children due to this disease which is
called troglodyte degeneration contagion
or tdc
which is why slaves were needed to
increase population we see the varying
effects of this throughout the pit with
slaves having skin conditions and
deformations and the trugs which are the
final stage of the disease
tdc is a creation of the terrible
working conditions of the mills which
are filled with pollution and toxins
mixed with the irradiated waters of the
river
a doctor here is stationed in the pit dr
sandra who's working with azure to solve
this disease and hopefully cure the
people
that cure is what werner wants once
inside we have to speak to medea a
subordinate of warner's that is the
inside man to help this operation flow
smoothly but before we can start though
we're interrupted and put on steel mill
duty which is 9 times out of 10
a death sentence to help us out with
this we can get a weapon from marco
which is the auto x but there's tons of
weapons inside the mill so it's not
necessary
all we need is 10 ingots but we can grab
up to a hundred the more we grab the
better the reward ranging from simple
clothing and weapons to full on power
armor from simply running around each
area picking up any that i found i ended
up with 87 ingots which is still a large
amount
and you can choose to find all 100
during this quest after the quest or
even after the dlc is finished so
there's no rush to finding all 100. the
steel mill is a large area and it's
highly recommended you go through all
areas not because of the ingots but
because of the loads of items you can
keep with you after it's done which
you'll be needing seeing as our gear was
taken at the gate
the plan for this quest is to meet asher
as warner explained numerous times
thankfully we got invited to the easiest
way to do it
the hole the hole is an arena-style
fighting pit all slaves can attempt this
fight
contestants are then placed in an arena
the match doesn't end until one dies or
they end up both dying due to the
makeshift timer of the barrels flying
down filled with radiation if the
contestant survives all three rounds
they're considered free and can meet
with asher and haven which is our goal
we go through these three fights taking
whatever we found with us and depending
on how much looting we did there's tons
of guns and armor to help us with this
once fighting all three were given
permission to meet asher asher
congratulates us on a job well done but
knows something's up as not many new
bloods can kill many people that quickly
in the pit you could play along and say
you wanted to join the raiders of the
pit or just flat out kill asher right
away
he tells us about werner and even if the
speech check fails we can promise him
that while we did meet him and he did
give us orders we don't trust him and we
like asher wayne morris to not blow our
cover
during our talk we're interrupted as
supposedly the slaves are fighting back
which is a hint that this is the signal
that werner was mentioning while asher
deals with this we meet up with sandra
in the sheer shock on my face when the
quest marker for the cure pointed me at
a child was unexplainable this child is
the cure warner wants
marie is the kid of asher and sandra and
i understand it's weird since no one in
the pic can have children but sandra
came from the outside and wasn't
subjected to the effects of the tdc
maria was born with an immunity to tdc
and the radiation which is exactly what
they need to help fight this disease and
all radiation throughout the whole
wasteland
this is where the quest divulges now
knowing everything you can leave with or
without the kid
taking the kid makes sandra hostile so
she has to die you turn maria over to
medea and go find werner so you can turn
off the powers the troggs can overrun
haven and
uptown lastly is dealing with asher and
then the slaves are saved if you take
the other route you return to medea
without marie who you can threaten to
find werner's location which makes him
hostile
both options have a similar ending
reward getting the ammo press which
takes ammo or scrap and turns it into
more ammo
as a test 50 scrap metal can produce
about a thousand rounds of 5 millimeter
ammo which is quite a bit
the dlc ending is what i want to discuss
though most choices have small moral
choices but this one is leagues above
the rest
if we side with asher we give him the
chance to keep working on the cure but
he keeps the slaves although he does
mention that if he does find the cure he
will give everyone their freedom and
stop slavery as now people can reproduce
and grow the town
if we side with warner the slaves are
freed but we also just made a baby an
orphan by taking her away and killing
her parents while also killing the one
doctor who's made the most progress
finding the cure
there is a hypothetical third option of
killing all four people medea werner
asher and sandra leaving no one in
charge of the pit and just leaving them
to fend for themselves and hopefully
abandon it some have claimed that the
pit is beyond saving so doing this would
be the best option regardless though
it's one of the best interesting
dilemmas this game has and one of the
best dlc's this game has as well
and just the sheer surprise that the
cure is a living breathing child
is absolutely insane and something i'm
never gonna forget the third dlc is
broken steel
broken seal continues after the events
of the main story regardless of the
ending you choose allowing you to see
your father's project to the end
there is also a level extension from
level 20 to level 30 with new perks in
between those
levels like changing your karma having
all the schematics unlocked or raising
all your special stats to level 9.
during the main quest the control room
explodes and we're knocked unconscious
no matter if we chose lions to do it or
ourselves when we awake elder lion still
needs our help even though the enclave
are scattered from the destruction of
raven rock they can still somehow
communicate with one another so we're
sent with our favorite robot to attack a
nearby relay station until liberty prime
is blasted away
bringing a tragic start to the dlc while
not many answers were found at the
station we did find some encrypted codes
that could help us
the scribe also sends us on a mission
through the deathclaw infested town of
old only to get a tesla coil this tesla
coil is for the tesla cannon we receive
in the next mission at the adams air
force base a check to the base is long
and covered with enemies of all kinds
when we make it to the air force base
though we're told that it's just us
against an entire armed base with the
only things that we have with us are the
tesla cannon and anything we brought
before the adventure you have to battle
through the whole base to find the air
traffic control tower so you can lower
the bridge on the mobile platform this
allows access inside the mobile platform
but our objective is now to blow it up
firstly by starting with the small
inside components like the repulsion
field and the control panel up to the
main control terminal which you can
choose two of five locations the base or
the citadel this is the player's
opportunity to destroy the brotherhood
of steel if they've disliked them the
whole game or you can finally finish off
the enclave in the capital wasteland
if you choose the brotherhood of steel
you're taken by vertebrae to see the
ruins of the building you're then caught
immediately and forced to fight them
if you somehow manage to fend them off
inside the citadelles piles of rubble
and one door that conveniently leads to
the armory
if you destroy the enclave you're then
taken by vertebrae to see the explosion
as the mobile platform explodes you can
then return to the base afterwards and
pick up some more tesla cannons and ammo
should you need it judging by the sheer
amount of enemies and the new types of
them being either power armor enclave or
deathclaws this is definitely a dlc for
the late game which is understandable
why it's only accessible after the main
story but depending on when you finish
the story it still may be too tough to
accomplish if you aren't prepared as you
are literally a single man fighting an
entire base
this dlc while fairly long as it's just
constant fighting is somewhat short if
you take those parts out
it's still a nice conclusion of the
ending of the game and the benefits of
10 more levels with more perks is always
a nice bonus this just really wasn't a
dlc that i've always enjoyed though
our fourth dlc is point lookout and
arguably the best dlc
added to the game the start of the quest
we must travel to the bottom of the map
to duchess gambit nearby is a lady who
needs help finding her daughter who went
to pilgrim's landing and never came back
in an effort to help her we take the
same trip
tobar the ferryman fills us in on the
island claiming there was an
undiscovered treasure on it when
arriving we're able to travel anywhere
we please
we'll handle the main quest for now then
delve into the side quest a little bit
later the main quest continues to the
calvert mansion inside is a man named
desmond who would love to chat if he
didn't have his hands full a group
called the tribals are raiding the
mansion and we need to stop them we go
to the different wings of the house then
finish up the main entrance to clear
everyone out
desmond then thanks us but still
requires some assistance he wants to
know why he was attacked so we have to
go undercover within the tribals to do
so this requires a ritual where we eat
the mother punga fruit this punka fruit
causes hallucinations similar to the
vault we
went in earlier in the video after these
hallucinations occur we can return to
the cathedral and gain entrance to the
tribe and depending on if you take your
helmet off you will notice that you have
a scar on your head
in the cathedral isn't the dean that
missing girl from the beginning she came
to the island to find the treasure to
have something of value to return with
she was then unsuccessful and ended up
joining the group to help procure the
punga fruit we still need to fulfill
desmond's quest which is to find out why
we're being attacked which can be done
by interrogating the leader it
discovered that the leader is simply a
pawn as the main leader is a talking
machine who used to be a person named
calvert
the owner of the mansion desmond tells
us that this calvert is one of his
archenemies and that he's been trying to
kill him for years
the game once again splits the choice
here either help calvert or help desmond
by planting or destroying a jammer that
desmond uses to keep calvert at bay
if we helped desmond we returned to see
the mansion blown up luckily he was in
the safe room and he still lives we
follow him to the lighthouse and kill
calvert if we don't help desmond the
mansion blows up but desmond once again
still lives if we kill him calvert
congratulations on a job well done that
attempts to backstab us no matter what
choice is picked though the back room is
open with a microwave emitter which is a
unique version of the mesmetron and tons
of ammo and items to take after
everything is done and you wish to
return we find nadine at the boat who
lets us know that tobar was the one
working with the tribe the whole time
he was the one who cut into our brain
and left the scar the visions were about
the procedure
the saw was him cutting us open the
needle was selling a shut and the bobble
heads are what tobar was saying during
the procedure which is a nice little
touch to the scene that some may not
catch
we can return nadine to her mom and she
says that she'll continue to drive us to
point lookout free of charge while the
main quest is pretty nice it can once
again take you an hour so the side
quests are always a highlight of the dlc
some are as simple as a nice horde mode
against ghouls but some can be a wild
goose chase for treasure the velvet
curtain starts in motel room 1d
when looking at a terminal we find a
chinese transmission we're now following
in the footsteps of an agent yang and
doing what
they were told to do we have to open a
safety deposit box which while something
small is fantastic as it needs voice
recognition and the only way to do that
is to play the hollow tape while you're
walking around the bank not looking at
it in your pip-boy
we then take the self-destruction codes
blow up the submarine and find the
hidden base for our reward only to find
out that agent yang was going to be set
up and killed so we now have to escape
not only is the treasure worth it in the
journey as there's tons of ammo and
weapons it was fantastic to embark on
regardless
of course if ammo and guns aren't your
cup of tea there's a ship that once the
safe is open contains tons of medical
supplies like i said before point
lookout is still and will always be my
favorite dlc
the atmosphere of the murky swamp filled
with hillbillies who shoot first and ask
questions later
couple with the unique story inside
quests make the roughly four hour
playtime all the more worth it
the very last dlc of fallout 3 was
mothership zeta a radio signal appears
which leads the player towards a crashed
alien ship we are then captured by
aliens our equipment is gone and the
only objective is to get our gear and
get out
this dlc adds a bunch of alien tech and
weapons and while not the best dlc to
some it's easily the best for those who
want to make easy caps as most of these
weapons are high in value but low in
weight mean you can carry tons of these
with you
i left the dlc with around 30 or so
alien pistols each around 350 to 500
caps
and two cannons worth about 1500 caps
and i still haven't sold them all yet
even if you don't have the room there's
still alien crystals on the ship that
don't have any weight meaning you can
carry tons of these without any
hindrance
but to even get to all that we need to
work with soma by staging a fight then
fighting the aliens we then meet sally
another prisoner on the ship who helps
us by sneaking around the ship and
opening things up for us we then have to
fight our way through the control center
in order to escape there is pods of
other kidnapped people and one of them
is an astronaut we need the suit of that
astronaut in order to do the spacewalk
so we can teleport to the different
portion of the ship the three members of
our crew are elliot a pre-war soldier
a cowboy named paulsen and a samurai
warrior named toshiro
to do the spacewalk we need to shut down
the systems in the cryolab hangar and
robot assembly after completing the
spacewalk we then proceed to disable the
death ray and kill the captain until the
rival ship arrives and we engage in some
ship combat
depending on how much you explore of
course you can actually find toshir
before he even arrives at the captain's
quarters as for some odd reason he just
mysteriously disappears
with the ship destroyed you and the
earth are saved and you can now return
home
mothership zeta isn't a long dlc by any
means and most of its length is due to
navigating the ship as it's very large
and convoluted the logs that you can
pick up from the station throughout the
ship provides much needed context and
story to what happened to other people
which is a nice change but honestly
mothership zeta has always been okay at
best for me it's a bit out there for
sure which is fine it's just not my
personal taste i usually play this dlc
for the gameplay benefits rather than
enjoy the story as it's a quite short
and nothing crazy which is why this dlc
section is so short because there's
really not much to talk about
with the end of the dlcs though we have
come to the end of the video fall 3 is
such a fantastic game and one that i'll
always come back to from time to time
just to immerse myself in the world
again when i forget the locations of the
capital wasteland almost as if it's my
first playthrough all over again thank
you for coming along on this journey
about my love letter to fallout 3. if
you enjoy this kind of style like the
video to let me know that you do and
with that i hope i'll see you in a
future video
take care and goodbye
[Music]
you